julio también es el mes del orgullo en
madrid con una semana de retraso por la
celebración de la cumbre de la otan
durante los últimos días de junio en la
capital española más de 2 millones de
personas en marchan por las calles
pidiendo
visibilidad orgullo y resiliencia en una
de las reuniones o manifestaciones más
grandes de europa y de las más grandes
del mundo frente al odio de los
discursos de odio hacia el colectivo
lgtb y tenemos que estar orgullosas
visibles y de frente no perder el norte
seguir caminando para conquistar
nuestros derechos creo que todos tenemos
que hacer libros de hacer lo que
queramos en el momento que queramos y
por eso hay que venir siempre a
defenderlo si esa primera se le olvidó
en madrid y también es la primera vez
este como bisexual
ahora este año para mí es algo
importante es una causa política también
y yo creo que eso es lo que tiene que
seguir siendo españa siempre se ha
considerado como un referente en cuanto
a los derechos del colectivo lgtb y sin
embargo en los últimos años no todo han
sido avances
no españa no es un referente yo he
sufrido mucho y no me han ayudado cada
vez hay más políticas que nos están
involucrando a que vayamos retrocediendo
que todas las cosas que una gente en los
años 60 ganaron y pelearon cada vez
nosotros no podemos permitir que existan
partidos políticos donde realmente no
estén reprimiendo o hagan cosas para que
nosotros podamos celebrar algo como esto
este 27 de junio
al proyecto de ley
esta secuencia de la portada
de género
[Música]
de ser aprobada por el legislativo
español varias
más
pero esto es tener objetivo